what up rejects we are going to watch
today from new rock stars moon night
episode 4 easter eggs and break down to
die from king erik voss eric hope to see
you at a certain movie premiere that's
right
i don't know any other upcoming movies
other than marvel who doesn't make the
joke
re-release of ambulance yeah
that's the punchline all right let's do
this
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of moon
night episode 4 which like mark and
steven made me scream holy hippopotamus
turns out i wasn't that delusional for
thinking some of this could be all in
steven's mind or could i still be
delusional probably still a bit
delusional i mean who knows what's going
on so i'm gonna break down this episode
shot by shot for the interesting details
you might have missed to best explain
one of the wildest twists we've ever
seen in the mcu true that son so we
begin this episode upside down as the
avatar for osiris places
in a cubby hole among several others our
view only finally orients writing itself
on this close-up of konshu making him
our compass our true north for what is
real this whole episode because without
him this hour mark steve and all of us
are lost i like how osiris avatar takes
this monster
beat after placing the ushapti since
they have clearly studified a ton of
deities not a healthy sign like a warden
wondering huh everyone is now in prison
are the laws too strict no it's everyone
else who's wrong also osiris may be
wondering
be the next one among these figurines
are a whole bunch of them one of the
birds another shorter one to the far
left a lot of these look like the larger
statues among the chamber last episode
towering over them i wonder if the five
members of the inead may have ushabti to
their ranking elders like ottoman shu
that could explain why four of the nine
indiana members are missing i also think
that tower rent may be amazing what's
happening at twitter and i'll explain
what that means for the final scene oh
so it sounds like that there's someone
on the council of the gods
oh who is slowly dwindling them all down
and wants to wield all the bat maybe the
chick who was hitting on uh who was
hitting
whatever her name was egyptian girl
yes
hot girl
couldn't grab it
especially because in the closing
credits of every episode on the back
right a tolerant ushabti appears
alongside these others which fill in the
cubbyholes we see in the opening shot
that tells us the tower at must be
banished which is a very important key
to how we interpret the final scene
throughout this opening scene we hear
several voices chanting
[Music]
as if these trapped gods and statues are
all haunting osiris demanding to be
freed then out in the desert a scarab
crawls up a mound and flies off now the
scarab was of course the compass that
was used to find ahmed sushapti and now
even this scarab complex is like uh
peace out you mortals suck now by the
way the hieroglyphics on that scarab
were translated to the phrase okepri
amid his boats primeval one whose
corporeality is infinity may you rescue
osiris a minitep true of voice capri
being the sundeep i know what that means
absolutely it does associated with the
way it rolled its dung across the sand
with the way capri rolled the sun across
the sky now remember last episode steve
duncan
casting that illusion to make the
heavens look like they did 2000 years
prior and when that happened the little
detail i liked steven's mr night mask
wilted away matching conscious
dissipation just a cool way of showing
how steven was losing a part of himself
as well no longer having the armor and
healing properties that really would
have come in handy when arthur shot him
twice in the chest but a detail that i
loved here whereas past episodes the
crescent moon always shine to reflect
conscious being at its most powerful now
notice how the moon is in its waxing
gibbous phase the exact opposite of the
waning crescent in the lunar cycle which
is a cool way wow what a great detail
totally weakened state now actually by
the way in the credits of every episode
of the season on the written by title
card it reflects the way the phases of
the moon shift episode after episode
from waxing crescent to the first
quarter to now in this episode gibbous
oh whoa so maybe it's on this like path
by the end of it it'll be a full moon
symbolizing the acceptance of the
personalities embracing moon night
yesterday becoming whole self-actual
lies you always get a different ending
credits and i feel like that's all woven
into the storytelling as well absolutely
it's good symbolism absolutely
absolutely it's my new word absolutely
don't you feel supported when someone
has absolutely no idea yeah i can't get
any more than that laila pulsa jurassic
park dr alan grant and lights a flare to
direct harrow's men away from the passed
out steven and then insanely throws
another lit flare into their box of
shells to set them all off like
fireworks even though in the shot from
behind her she is clearly totally
exposed to all of those projectiles
folks the indiana jones antics go way
over the top of this episode and i truly
think it is by design to suggest mark
could be pulling all this from his tomb
buster movie actually as they drive into
the desert the next morning these
locations were the same parts of jordan
where they shot indiana jones the last
crusade so that familiarity is totally
intentional meanwhile may kill him
always look in the show and the way she
plays layla definitely evokes rachel
vice from the morning movies i really
think these cinematic parallels are all
by design make the mummy cannon i might
think in a lot of ways she also
resembles knows karen allen she does
yeah she does that's a good call she was
reminding me of her very much throughout
especially that episode yeah she gets
drunk and beats men at gambling tables
maybe that's how we'll meet jake
locklear is they'll have a shots contest
leila and steven agree to keep mark out
of it the camera lingers on these three
bullet holes in the windshield which you
could see as representative of the three
alters we think make up mark's mind the
way that the holes can be in there
without breaking or shattering the whole
thing because mark is not broken those
three altars we assume are mark stephen
and jake lockley as of this episode we
have not yet met jake they pass a goat
who stares them down in addition to the
christian associations between goats and
evil there was that moment with stephen
episode bafflement
yes
where there is a there is a hero koi was
speculating that men have like goat
spies i like it which i think would add
a whole new layer of horrors we got
earlier than a goat watching what's
scary the goat watching you plus we got
god goats coming up in thor love and
thunder and what's scarier than a than a
goat god who could watch you and
transport
my cats drink goat milk dude they're got
the powers going in you gotta stop that
now yeah yeah
and sidenote i'm actually hoping that
the third personality is the astronaut
man who fights werewolves
in space i think that would
probably transition nicer than jake
lockley in all honesty now when stephen
initially wants to make a move on layla
mark punches his own face in the jaw
oh [ __ ] another fight club reference
tyler durden does essentially the same
thing
oh yeah going back and forth with layla
stephen finally makes his move and it is
awkward i'm gonna go down okay first
before i belay thank you yes steve you
totally misinterpreted it down to mean
uh not belay but you know another
another kind of down uh a sex kind diddy
what mate baby suggesting
that
he
go straight to third or fourth or
whichever base that is yeah no matter
where you are that's just the protocol
stephen geeks out at the statues down
there they're just like
been standing guard for centuries i'm
right
i can't even
if they just sprang to life right now
and
ask me a riddle for passage i i'd be
thrilled i [ __ ] myself but i'd be
thrilled yes he's referring to the
riddle of the sphinx the sphinx being
the creature with the haunches of a lion
the wings of a bird it's best known from
greek mythology where it has the head of
a woman but in egyptian mythology it has
the head of a man to the ground guards
the riddle to oedipus what creature has
one voice yet becomes four-footed and
then two-footed and then three-footed an
oedipus answered correctly man who
crawls on all fours as a baby walks on
two feet as an adult and uses a walking
stick in old age three beings in one
also parallels mark and his alters each
of whom have a different stride yet
speak in one voice and one cannot help
but draw a connection to the caned
figure of arthur harrow who ends this
episode using his walking stick this is
also of course a big clue for the reveal
of alexander the great for the way
egyptian iconography and obelisk since
sphynx has made their way into greece
was because of alexander's occupation of
egypt and his obsession with egypt in
the sand leila traces the arabic letters
going from right to left because that's
how arabic works mine and elif her
father's initials as we saw her full
name on her passport last episode leila
abdullah el fauli abdullah meaning
servant of god which is a bit ironic
because mark is trying to keep her from
being a servant to the god conscious oh
man if
there are fools out there who get mad at
the movie thor love and thunder when
they see jane foster and are like
wow
can you imagine if moon night season two
that's the layla who's moonlight
that's right man she's a mary sue she
just got all these god powers out of
nowhere now she's kicking ass
not my moon night do it do it cowards
while exploring the tunnels layla says
it's a maze
it's amazing
no like there are six paths yeah
six of course since this episode ends by
suggesting much of this could have been
all in mark's mind it's worth noting
that the concept of a maze has often
been considered a symbol of the
subconscious mind back to greek
mythology the labyrinth and then
manifesting in contemporary media like
stanley kubrick's the shining westworld
and the amazing series severance watch
that show it's so good this
represents mark's mind perhaps the six
paths representing as many as six altars
stored inside but steven traces out the
structure to show how this is modeled on
the eye of horus and it's six parts such
a good drawing symbol that some
historians interpret to represent the
sixth senses of thought sight hearing
smell and taste according to mythology
horus's right eye was the sun and the
left eye the moon and this is his left
eye here so the moon is always present
in this show but in the mythology there
was a fight between horus and his
brother set and set tore out the eye and
the eye is later healed and restored
either by tot or by hawthor whom we met
last episode which is why this is simple
now that's her name there we go we got
to remember him
to trace this his flashlight now
reflects off of the metallic surface
beneath to form the eye of horus on the
ceiling above them as if either horus or
hawthor could be watching over the deeds
here or this represents the moon that
konchu is watching all of this then they
come across this mummification chamber
used by these undead priests who are
buried alongside the pharaoh on the
upper level mark finds some stuff that
he says was used in regeneration rituals
which all just leads to this gore fest
in the middle of the episode where the
priest extracts organs from harrow's man
and tries to do it to mark and layla who
knows why he's doing this layla comes
across as gaping pit reminding us of the
chasm that indiana jones has to make the
leap of faith across
yeah that's what i said she did it she
got the rap her faith and her love for
mark despite the bad stuff he was
involved with she has to fend off this
priest monster by ripping off his arm
and shoving a flare in his face she
loves her flares 40 pieces of flare on
this one now this zombie crease makes a
clicking sound
cause he got nothing which comes off
pretty creepy but this is actually the
result of his tongue being removed from
the involvement he said that he says
killing at this episode as well the
clicking allows him to echolocate his
targets around the tomb the way bats use
similar clicking sounds and when his
hand reaches out of the wall
it's very similar to the frame of the
corpse or reaching the subway door in
the comics when mark's mental hospital
reality warps around him meanwhile
steven finds some macedonian language on
the foot of the tomb actually if you
translate the back half of those letters
they really translate to alexander
confirming this huge discovery for
stephen i think we're looking
at the long-lost team
that's right right there in plain sight
alexander the great you should know this
guy he was the one who by the age of 30
led the greeks
alleged empires in human history from
europe to india alexander was a lover of
egyptian history who also bore the title
of pharaoh he founded the city of
alexandria where many believe after his
death in babylon in 323 bc he could now
be buried somewhere in the city of
alexandria but his tomb has never been
pinpointed and verified so unless this
is all a fantasy in that's why
the implication here is still mysteries
out there and the history of the mcu was
the final avatar of ahmet and that
alexander's military feats might have
been enabled by amit's power and maybe
even the cult-like love that alexander
inspired could have been the same kind
of cult following that arthur harrow now
enjoys famously the saying goes that
alexander wept because there were no
worlds left to conquer therefore
alexander might have been that past
avatar who betrayed amit he could have
been the one who sold her out to the
gods and her detachment from him is what
led to his death in babylon can you
imagine getting alexander the great in
this show and even any capacity dude
really messing with like historical
fiction i want it get colin farrell to
come in you know and be alexander and
then have him meet athena and have a
whole weird multiversal conversation
about the internals of why she looks
just like his mom who else is in that
movie uh
just jeremy irons in it
alfred i think there's an elephant at
one point yeah oh hey and they're
elephants in wakanda right or those
rhinos that they're riding
right horn pretty sure those are
ostriches yes that's right of course
after which point the indiana said ahmet
you have helped out humanity way too
much no one should have conquered that
much turf you a statue and then had
someone stuff that statue in his mouth
you wanted her to be your voice eat her
eater i like it i want to go down
this with its wings open evoking
harrow's scarab compass that he uses to
find her x marking the spot for amit
sushapti which is buried deep in
alexander's gullet alexander's axe that
he's holding might have actually been
the one he famously used to cut the
gordian knot but harrow reveals to layla
that mark was among the mercenaries who
killed her father and she confronts him
talking to you i'm talking to you mark
come on let's go let's go let's go yeah
steven immediately nopes out of this
marital drama and i just like how the
frame breaks the rule of 180 to show
this transition i'm really cutting to
the oscillator now switches to the right
side of the frame and mark affirms that
while he did not kill leyla's dad he was
still there my partner got greedy and he
he executed everyone else excited he
shot me too i was supposed to die that
night i'm assuming this partner was
frenchy to comp whose name appeared on
mark's flip bone promo footage has shown
the moment mark first got possessed by
konchu i assume next episode episode 6
will show us what this backstory was at
least in the comment that this one's
mainly inspired from it wasn't frenchy
right who got greedy no frenchie was on
mark's side yeah it was bush bushman
bushman it was the bushman it was the
bush world adventure
erotic that they would do a jurassic
park reference in here when in the comic
the character that layla is based off of
marlene her dad looks like sam neil
straight out of jurassic park it's like
honoring the inspirations of the source
material that was inspired by other
media together i feel like that's an
actual real contribution to one of these
pauses yes it is it is a good
contribution to one of these pauses you
should appreciate if you made it yeah we
added to the video finals yeah hero and
his men arrive the rest is silence yes
another shakespeare reference after
macbeth's something wicked in episode 1
and the romeo and juliet verona light of
episode 2 the rest is silence are the
final words spoken by hamlet and hamlet
after his long drawn-out death from
being cut with the poisoned sword and
his duel with laertes after that cut
hamlin actually goes on and on for
merely 100 lines so shakespeare ends his
life with those words and almost a
self-satirical tone like the kid finally
shutting up after going back and forth
on death for five acts when you think
about it the line is actually a pretty
good pun the rest is silence but also
the rest is silence and in this we can
draw a comparison with mark you did well
in english class wondered might already
be dead in this whole series is his
passage through the field of reeds and
did it suck for you getting rejected
from the field debates i said
foreshadowing dude
steve
and hero is now preparing to lay the
final nail in the coffin hero does this
by shooting mark twice in the chest and
mark slowly falls backward matching the
fall last episode when he blacked out
similarly mark is out of control not
sure what his signature falls in because
he passes out from overhead in just
inches of water but when we cut to him
from below we are now several meters
deeper than him in that water as he
descends into this sunken place where
now you'll notice the bullet holes are
gone from his chest showing how mark has
sunken from his passage of the field of
reeds now more like that sunken boat and
poor sarcophagus in the tank as we saw
mark reflected submerged in that tank in
episode two and now we find ourselves in
this low budget jungle set of tomb
buster a title clearly an indiana jones
ripoff even its name and nodded the tomb
raider franchise but this scene is
totally similar to the opening of
raiders of the lost ark when indy and
doc ock found the remains of the
previous adventurer even the music sting
is almost note for note john williams
indiana jones theme
[Music]
so the implication of this is that mark
might have pulled the name in the heroic
expertise of steven grant from this
movie almost like someone in our world
manifesting an altar named dr jones a
princeton archaeologist and a venturer
but notice how instead of the egyptian
moon
they explore the aztec moon deity of
koyoshaki who is depicted here with
multiple faces like the split
nice oh that's great it's interesting
that while ethan hawke's endless
character later compares himself to the
villain of this movie this doctor steven
grant really does physically resemble
arthur hero his hair his glasses his
usage of the compass actually that
villain in the movie is never named for
all we know this indiana jones figure
might end up being revealed to be the
villain of that movie the kid who looks
up to him the hero just like as we watch
mark spector and steven grant and arthur
herrera on this show we don't really
know who the villains and the heroes are
because konchu is kind of steve's this
whole twist is awesome several
characters in the cast reappear all of
them now in this facility street before
we're crawling that was right
[Laughter]
[Music]
vp of the episode he's always laid out
in front of him in the park the bald man
fidgets with a rubik's cube almost
completing the white side as we saw in
steven's flat i'm pretty sure that's the
tour guide dylan stevens date sitting at
the table behind the ball guy the
orderlies are bobby aka kennedy the fake
detective while the other pushing us
from mark's point of view here in the
wheelchair is billy aka fitzgerald their
names were a major clue of this reveal
because in the comics billy and bobby
are the names of orderlies who work in
mark's mental hospital also in the
comics crawley is revealed to be another
resident at the hospital at some point
the same way he is here the red yellow
and blue bowls of jello are just like
the brightly colored powder in all the
bowls that steven saw in the
mummification room donna is another
patient clutching one of the plush
scarabs that they sell in the museum
inventory out this we hear the ticking
of a clock which we passed right after
we see donna but it looks like it reads
11 25 but the hour hand ends in the
shape of a crescent moon but despite the
ticking sound the second hand of that
clock is not moving there's a cupcake
cart just like the cupcake fan that's
even hijacked in episode one
i wanted a bird with cool introduces
both konshu of course but also the
hummingbirds
nature footage on the dry erase board
are pinned some postcards like the one
stephen thinks he receives from his mom
here it is layla who does it so maybe
the mum he thought he was connecting
with was actually layla there's
on a stack of books just like gus's tank
and steven's flat that is cluttered with
books layla appears chewing on a turkish
delight just like the ones that the
forger shared with her in episode three
a lot of sweet snacks in this facility
notice how she's
the red drawing of a scarab on it this
is a major clue pointing to the
possibility that layla abdullah alfajoli
could be an adaptation of abdul
aka the scarlet scarab an egyptian
warrior who led the sons of a scarab who
fought against the invaders cap human
torch namor bucky spitfire and union
jack as other titles have done
retconning flag smasher as carly
morgenthau and laura barton as
mockingbird layla could be reframed as a
successor of a lineage of egyptian
protectors
if you thought people were upset
about thor loving thunder be like oh
jakes j foster's lady though
that's what happens when they find out a
comic character they didn't even know
about
that's not a woman
now they're gonna have to get used to an
origin all dedicated to her
but i do love this setting of the easter
eggs man i'm just assumed they're just
in the uh and uh the other void or over
void yeah the overvoice yeah maybe she
could be the scarlet scarab and the uh
konshu moon
very likely two sets of powers that make
people even happier but i love how it's
more detail-oriented and reflective of
the episodes we've saw sometimes people
reach in these theory and easter egg
videos but this one seems very accurate
so good job ryan airy a man behind them
gardens like the gardeners at harrow's
commune layla says he won at bingo
holding up his card that shows the
following numbers dabbed b83 i23 n86 g65
g35 o67 and o55 and throughout this we
heard probably
b22 g15 t16 oh 40 something oh 73 and
n39 folks if you've ever played bingo
these numbers make no sense the b
numbers go 1 through 15 i is 16 through
30 and it's 31 through 45 g is 46
through 60 and o is 61 through 75. most
of these letters and numbers would not
exist in bingo also crowley clearly said
t16 as in tango 16 and there is no t in
bingo in high school spanish class i
played a spanish version of bingo called
tingo where you say yo tinko i have it
bingo then a medicated mark falls out of
his wheelchair that's probably the first
clue this isn't real
on the exact same side of his face
one when he landed in the alps in
episode two when he left out of bed i
love how those two moments set up this
reveal here in his hand is this hooded
and caped moon knight action figure
which if moon knight ain't a really
known hero in the mcu at this point
would there be an action figure of him
also another weird thing what was he
dabbing his bingo guard with i didn't
see a dabber in his hand then onto
harrow's office mark sees his painting
of the exact landscape of the alps where
steven found himself in episode one but
harrow now the analyst of this facility
says we don't live in a material world
we live in a
psychic world i mean harrow's office we
are not material girls columns tall
ceilings brick surfaces and arches
they're these headed vases just like the
ones that the priests store the organs
one has the falcon head of raw as well
as the hippo head of towerette and this
human head that i think matches the
sarcophagus of alexander the great
harrow has a cane that mark assumes that
he must have mapped the ahmed staff over
and of course sandals just like the ones
he fills with glass and notice how mark
sees those sandals through the
reflection of a mirror a household lands
on mark's hand maybe a reflection of his
riding corps status back in the tomb
also reminding us of the final shot of
alfred hitchcock's psycho when norman
bates's mother voice said that she
wouldn't even have to let her fly that
landed on her also on the desk are a
bunch of sharp things that should not be
on a desk of this kind of facility
there's a large curved piece that
matches the shape of a crescent moon as
well as a pyramid and if you look
closely at that vhs cover of tomb buster
it says when deeper in here steven grant
has no fear which isn't the case in the
final shot of the episode but maybe a
clue that stephen grant in a place like
this is going to be the more heroic
figure dr hero says i can't help you
if you don't help yourself which is what
harrow said after shooting stephen in
that tomb
i can't save anyone who won't save
themselves by the door is another statue
the crocodile head of ahmet and as
harrow steps up to mark at the door he's
just framed with this close-up of his
hand on the cane the way he's been
framed in several other shots like the
opening scene of the series as mark
flees the hallways just warp the carts
are rolling on their own the hanging
lights just swing back and forth looking
a lot like the swinging scales of amit's
justice we've also been seeing this
hallway in the closing credits imagery
flickering from the storage unit hallway
into this one and if you remember back
in episode two the waste even ran down
that hallway is the same way mark runs
down this one both of these forming
amazing
yes
i love it
hold on i think what's happening is i
think they are pulling exactly from this
versus the new rockstars video i'll be
more direct
i think they are pulling from the lemire
run like pretty pretty fully
where this is ahmet's world right right
yeah she's disguised dr emmett yeah yeah
and then it has the orderlies like it's
so much from that comic run and i
imagine that that is exactly what we
have entered into at this point
absolutely and i don't want to get too
far off road but it almost seems like
they could play it almost like a like a
saw movie time twist where it's like
this was what stephen was or mark was
going through at the times when stephen
was freaking out or in control of the
body on the earth plane or something
yeah like maybe these runs line up down
the hallway more than we think they were
and they're gonna do exactly within the
comp which is gonna get layla he's gonna
get crowley he's gonna get out there to
get her to ship with
anubis and
you know
in the avengers show he finds this
sarcophagus
[Music]
this is the first time that the two
altars have actually touched physically
suggesting that they are in the same
sunken place inside of his mind they
actually had oscar isaac's brother
michael hernandez stand in for him
during these scenes wow this smooth
character looks so different like we
never cut from oscar isaac at the door
to oscar isaac coming out of the
sarcophagus but you can see there is a
hidden cut on the whip pan i also like
here how mark is dressed in light garb
where steven is dressed in darker
clothes which not only helps us
distinguish the two but also frames
which one of these two altars is closer
to konshu mark notices another
mysterious sarcophagus that shakes
another room that they don't open i am
assuming that this is going to be the
mystery third alter maybe jake lockley
whoever it was who stabbed those men on
the roof last night
and then we ended on this awesome moment
mikey hippopotamus
valley eric so bottomless
so this is towerette the egyptian deity
of childbirth infertility who takes on
the appearance of a hippopotamus but
with otherwise human features the kind
of features disney plus definitely had
to cover with a more modest wardrobe i
just love the hippopotamus animation
details that they added like the way her
ears wiggle when she says hi and the way
her nostrils flare she's voiced by
actress antonia saleem confirmed at the
red carpet premiere last month and she's
credited for this episode as well as
episodes five and six so we're gonna
spend a lot of time with her so what is
going on well the moon knight comics
especially the jeff lemire and greg
smallwood run that seems most
influential on this series constantly
shifting back and forth from mark's
natural experiences to a clinical
setting repeatedly making the reader
second guess what could be real and what
could be a delusion this state of
uncertainty is exactly what moon knight
is supposed to feel like and there is
enough surreality and falseness in both
mark and steven's experiences in the
outside world and their experiences in
the hospital to doubt the legitimacy of
either reality even before tower it
walks in no mental hospital looks like
this where's cupcake cards meanwhile all
the enemies
it's also super silly and fictitious so
is anything on the show real well i see
three explanations first explanation the
past episodes with stephen and mark in
the outside world was all a fantasy
constructed by a patient in a mental
hospital a patient who still suffers
from delusions while in this hospital
kind of like how all of saint elsewhere
was in the mind of autistic child tommy
westfall patient who dreamt all this up
might be neither mark nor stephen who if
you think about it are both pretty
heightened realities but rather a more
grounded figure the guy and the other
sarcophagus may be jake explanation too
everything we have seen happen
pre-hospital is real but now after he
got shot mark slipped into a kind of
limbo state deep in his subconscious
that takes the form of a mental hospital
filled with people and images from his
life like dorothy gail after she hit her
head and went to oz or like tony soprano
when he had that hallucination after he
got shot but explanation 3 mark spectre
has already been in the process of dying
a long drawn-out process like our boy
hamlet and this whole time he has been
passing through the field of reeds the
brooms were the wreaths
[Music]
a purgatorial judgment process for a man
with d.i.d to reach peace with his
altars before the rest is silence i mean
i don't know but this third explanation
might help us understand what this
hospital now is why it is filled with
sarcophagi and tauret now yes the
hindquarters of ahmed are that of a
hippopotamus maybe they're going to draw
a parallel with amit being three in one
the way mark is and here amit's altars
are depicted as separate people but
again towerette is her own deity the
goddess of fertility i don't see how
fertility applies much to what steven
and mark are going through but there was
a connection in the past if you remember
episode one when steven handled some of
those plush towerettes while doing
inventory in the museum bring those
hippos up here will you yeah sure oh god
car wet it
the hippo got his towel with it which is
why whoa
[Music]
dozens and dozens of gods trapped
somewhere there was that one interesting
line from dr harrow where he quoted the
villain of toon buster no tree can
ascend to the light of heaven if it
doesn't descend to the depths of hell
heaven and hell above and below konchu
accused the members of the iniad for
hiding in the overvoid now i think we
could be in the mcu's underworld a realm
that may end up going by many names in
the mcu maybe even has already been
introduced in the form of the ancestral
plane this is a subjectively psychic
dimension where reality manifests itself
in the eyes of the beholder to a did
patient a mental hospital with egyptian
flare because trapped in him with this
realm of mark and his altars and
projections of people in his life are
the other egyptian gods that the inead
banished to the underworld ahmet kanchu
and this sexy ass tower ant well that uh
i was really really absorbed into that
and really taking it all in yeah i was
like watching a sawtwist exactly
oh my god what's real what is time who
is where he's really really reflected in
that for
hot for solid few minutes definitely a
toss up between exploration two and
explanation three for me because
explanation two would probably be the
easier path to descend down but
explanation three seems to thematically
represent everything that's been going
on
much more aptly so i'm not sure which
one it would actually be i feel like
they're both really plausible and the
only differentiator for me is that
explanation two feels like an easier
thing to make work over like a long
developing story or whatever whereas
explanation three feels like the more
finite this is
what this piece wants to speak about
kind of thing and this is what's been
happening the whole time versus
transitioning into a new kind of show
yeah absolutely yeah so it's probably
explanation three but then would that
mean mark would die in the end no no no
he finds a way that's actually kind of
like the lumiere run too yeah whereas he
really believes he's gonna die yeah but
you know
and said he gets like 10 more
personalities made out of hot women and
he sleeps with the mom
that's yeah that's the afterlife right
there just all up here without yeah
really insulting to mental health i'm
telling you guys mental health to
various religions it's not it's not
subversive material blame the comics not
us no tree can ascend to the heavens
without descending to the depths of hell
is also a paraphrase of a quote from
famous philosopher and psychoanalyst
carl young who said quote no tree it is
said can grow to heaven unless its roots
are in hell this was young's way of
saying human enlightenment is impossible
unless we recognize our inner demons
that collectively haunt us this being a
reflection of this stage in mark's
hero's journey to descend into hell
before he can reach true consciousness
and again since stone who shot the tower
appears in the credits of every episode
and presumably also in that wall of
cubby holes with all the other stone who
shot these who have been exiled
somewhere that right there may be proof
that we are now in the duat the
underworld that all exiled gods are
trapped in and mark's soul is currently
with them back in episode two when
stephen was handed a pamphlet to help
from a mental health yes
how is subconscious the subconscious of
a did patient decorates the egyptian
underworld of the duat this show's
version of the mcu afterlife the
ancestral plane valhalla wherever the
hell thanos went to and in this case how
this hero takes the plunge into the
depths of hell and prepares to fight his
way back out of it and a reminder to
check out our merch options
merch crazy stuff yeah mine bending
secret message on it you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at e8 boss
following rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
konshu ah conscious guys that was banana
sandwich crazy time but the bastard
robins you know what i mean i love bats
everyone has like 33 flavors and they're
like we only offer 31. mom there's two
more flavors here they didn't know about
and why isn't scott lang taking my order
a bunch of con artists over at bastard
robbins tell you holding out on them
customers i got a bone to pick with ceo
basketball
so if you're watching this video get in
touch can't wait to see what happens i
can't wait to be wrong by episode 5.
dude i've never been more right about
anything you were on fire this episode i
got a couple things you got a bunch of
deep cuts dude i got a bunch i didn't
know at all
i still got it
all right guys so let's say thanks for
being here subscribe to new rock stars
they're all geniuses great editors great
thumbnailers great hosts and writer eric
boss
guys keep up the great work get some
shirts from them
see you guys soon
peace